(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] This incredible glacier,
located in Alaska, is a
popular tourist destination.
But the best way to see
it is from the inside.
(soft piano music)
Mendenhall Glacier is
a 12-mile long glacier
in the Mendenhall Valley
in Alaska's Tongass National Forest.
The ice caves are the
glacier's surreal interior.
Access to see these icy walls
are only available to
the truly adventurous.
To see the ice caves
requires a kayak trip,
an ice climb over the glacier,
and once you're inside, the faith
that the melting walls
around you won't give away.
But this natural wonder is under threat.
The glacier has been retreating
incredibly quickly in recent years
due to warmer temperatures
and rising sea levels.
It has receded by almost
two miles since 1958.
But what remains is an utterly
breathtaking fantasy land.
(soft piano music)
(techno beep)